لدينا صراعنا الخاص الذي
نخوضه نحن ممتنون
للعالم لدعم كفاحنا
[موسيقى]
عواطفنا تجعل
الأقلية البيضاء عدوًا
يجب ألا نتحدث معهم أبدًا
ولكن دماغنا قال
إذا لم تتحدث مع هذا الرجل
ستشتعل النيران في بلدك
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] لقد كرست
حياتي لهذا النضال الذي
يخوضه الشعب الأفريقي الذي حاربته
ضد
الهيمنة
البيضاء وفكرت
ضد هيمنة السود ،
إنها
فكرة أنا
مستعد للموت من أجلها
[  الموسيقى]
من الأخطاء
التي يرتكبها بعض
التكريمات السياسية الاعتقاد بأن
أعداءهم
يجب أن يكونوا أعداءنا
[الموسيقى]
لذا فإن
للرياضة [الموسيقى] القدرة على تغيير
العالم ولديها القدرة
على
إلهامها ولديها القدرة على توحيد الناس
بطريقة تجعلنا صغارنا
نتحدث
إلى الشباب
بلغة يفهمونها
[موسيقى]
لديك وقت محدود للبقاء
على الأرض ،
يجب أن تحاول استخدام تلك الفترة
لغرض تحويل بلدك
إلى ما تريد  أن تكون
[موسيقى]
أنت